ist jetzt wahrscheinlich kratzt das
zuhören
hallo mein name ist luca und ja wir
müssen reden ich mag youtube also das
soll überhaupt nicht gegen die plattform
gehen oder die leute die diese
plattformen kreiert haben oder gegen
irgendwelche anderen personen allerdings
ist die entwicklung in letzter zeit
nicht so cool und es fakt mich irgendwie
alles ein bisschen gerade ab deswegen
wollte ich ganz kurz über etwas aber ich
hatte den kompletten september frei von
der uni weil ich ende august versuchen
geschrieben habe das heißt ich war
nahezu den kompletten september zu hause
bei meiner familie und haben von dort
videos produziert bei mir ist es so
immer wenn ich hier bei mir zu hause in
meiner wohnung bin kümmere ich mich
unglaublich viel um studien kran es
macht unglaublich viel mit freunden und
investieren nicht so viel zeit in
youtube wenn ich allerdings zu hause bei
meiner familie bin ist das einzig in
meinem leben was dann quasi hautnah das
sag ich mal so ist dann wirklich youtube
was jetzt so business und arbeiten um
eine workflow angeht deswegen haben
beispielsweise auch die videos die ich
im september produziert habe deutlich
mehr ausufert sie die ich beispielsweise
jetzt gerade produziere wo ich jetzt
wieder am studieren bin und hier zu
hause in bei mir allein in meiner
studienstadt bin aber das erst mal so zu
den zahlen sachen und euch zu zeigen das
ist mir in diesem video wirklich nicht
um diese ganzen aufrufe und abonnenten
zu wechseln gehen weil ich weiß selber
wenn ich zeit in youtube investiere ich
meine schauen uns einfach mal den
september als beispiel ich hatte den
kompletten september frei hab mich da
wirklich von morgens 9 uhr nach dem
aufstehen direkt schauen und hey was
geht irgendwie ab was die trends worüber
könnte ich heute ein video machen ich
habe im september wirklich jeden tag in
youtube investiert und ich habe im
september über 100000 neue abonnenten
gemacht über 32
millionen video views und das war der
krasseste monat den ich je in meiner
kompletten fünfjährigen youtube laufbahn
hatte also das war ganz kurz zu dem
aspekt ich mache dieses video nicht weil
ich irgendwie den zahlen hinterher
trauer oder so sondern ich weiß selber
wenn ich jetzt meine wochen ihren uni
gehen würde könnte ich locker auch
wieder krass oder zahlen erreichen weil
ich mich einfach mehr mit der materie
auseinandersetzen könnte also es soll
ich heute gar nicht darum gehen dass ich
irgendwie traurig bin weil die klicks
bisschen runtergegangen sind ich will
mich heute viel mehr auf die kommentare
beziehen
gestern habe ich beispielsweise eine
drohne zugeschickt bekommen und haben
dann einfach ein video hochgeladen wo
ich schwach mit der drohne gemacht habe
und dann am ende gefragt habe wenn ihr
der ideen habt schreibt gerne meine
kommentare und wünscht man sich dann
halt als youtuber kommentare die
wirklich in die richtung gehen ja mach
mal mehr mit der drohne oder her ich
habe hier die idee macht doch mal dies
und das mit der drohne oder wow das hier
werd voll cool das mal ausprobieren
könnte stattdessen kommen also
kommentare die beispielsweise erste im
kommentare ich weiß du keinem bereich
des flughafens liegt nur ihren gleich
zehn jahre paid ps bei mir gibt es trenc
schaut mal vorbei fliege ich vielleicht
und ich live was soll das ich weiß es
sind jetzt nur vier beispiele und 4
kommentare aber jeder davon hat
unglaublich viele likes und ich sehe es
auch unter anderem videos von mir das
schreiben die leute like it mit dem du
triffst geld und ab und ihr mich und du
wirst glücklich und nur stark sondern
haben wieder teilweise so 2006 drauf ich
will euch gar nicht unterstellt an die
leute die solche dummen kommentare
schreiben dass sie da irgendwelche
lightbox habt oder das mit irgendwelchen
zwei rekordhoch pusch damit ihr erst mal
angezeigt werden es kann auch sein dass
einfach die community also ihr das ein
bisschen nach offside und denken so hohe
ok es muss sich das leitungsteam ich
pech oder so aber für mich als creator
auf dieser plattform ist es unglaublich
beschissen wie meine kommentare
anzuschauen und in denen ich
konstruktive kritik erwartet zum lesen
oder irgendein feedback zum video man
sich halt nur
beschissene scheiße das fakt mich so ab
ich weiß das thema jeder youtuber auf
der welt schon mal ein video gemacht hat
wo er die plattform youtube gehandelt
hat weil die in lens als einen wirklich
also ich glaube wir wissen alle dass
youtube in letzter zeit sehr viel
scheiße gebaut hat es irgendwelche
änderungen von denen uns trader nichts
berichtet wurde oder irgendwelche sachen
wo abonnenten gelöscht wurden und wo
youtube nicht mehr wusste was da
eigentlich passiert so das kann einfach
nicht sein dass könnt ihr nicht bringen
warum auf den punkt zu kommen jeder
youtuber hat irgendwie schon mal video
gemacht wo er die plattform so ein
bisschen gehemmt ist hat dafür oder
zumindest etwas aufgezeigt was falsch
läuft und bei vielen wasser wichtig
dieser aspekt dass die kommentarfunktion
nämlich total beschissen wurde seitdem
youtube diese google+ verknüpfung der
eingebaut hat das sehr viel größere
youtuber netz stellte dann schon mal
gemacht haben war die kommentare zu
deaktivieren und dann nach einem monat
oder so wieder zu aktivieren um zu sehen
ob die leute das irgendwie gelernt haben
und dann quasi zu schauen ob das ganze
sich irgendwie verbessert hat oder
irgendwelche verbesserungen aufgetreten
sind ich finde aber dass das nicht
erfolgs bringend sein kann wenn man
etwas deaktiviert und nach hinter
aktiviert das wäre so wie wenn man den
leuten den mund verbietet deswegen
möchte ich etwas machen was ich als
erfolgs dringendste maßnahme halte weil
der derzeitige situation und zwar die
aktiviere ich die bewertungen ab heute
für eine woche ist jetzt wahrscheinlich
kratzt das zuhören ich mache das nicht
weil mein content übel geheilt wird und
weil ich angst davor habe so viele
displays zu kassieren oder so ganz im
gegenteil in letzter zeit wurden meine
videos wirklich echt cool geleitet und
die leute da mir da nicht gezeigt dass
ihnen der content gefällt und da war
nicht wenig des live im vergleich aber
ich bin eher der ansicht dass wir die
kommentar sektion verbessern können wenn
wir einfach die leute zwingen nicht ein
video zu bewerten
nach den likes oder nachdem dislike
sondern wirklich danach einen kommentar
zu schreiben wenn ich mir beispielsweise
so meine letzten videos bei angucke
haben sie immer so zwischen 30 und 50
tausend natürlich mehr mal weniger aber
die haben immer nur so um die 4000
kommentare das heißt locker 80 prozent
geben einfach nur daumen hoch oder
daumen runter und nur 20 prozent oder
noch viel weniger schreiben einfach ein
kommentar und nehmen sich diese kurze
zeit etwa ein kleines statement zu
schreiben und um jetzt noch mal aufs
ziel zu kommen was ich hiermit erreichen
will und zwar will ich einfach dass die
kommentare sich wirklich auf das video
beziehen und das so eine scheiße wie
like und du bist toll und ignorieren die
scheiße dass das einfach rausgekegelt
wird oder dieses ganze unnötige diese
unnötigen kommentare mich macht einfach
nur traurig und ich mach das derzeit
nicht so wie einige andere youtuber und
sage ich deaktiviere die kommentare
damit sich die reaktivierung hoffe dass
es besser ist weil das ist eigentlich
nie der fall sondern ich deaktiviere die
bewertungen und zwinge euch wenn man so
will dazu einen kommentar zu schreiben
und das ist einfach das gibt mir so viel
mehr rückmeldung weil über einen like
oder dislike es kann sein dass solches
video des leighton nur weil das lied dem
nicht gefällt man bekommt einfach über
diese bewertungen keinen richtigen
aufschluss darüber wie ein video den
leuten gefallen warum es jemandem
gefallen hat warum ist jedoch nicht
gefallen was man besser machen könnte
und um zu kommen leute ich die
aktivieren die bewertungen für die
nächsten sieben tage und ich bitte euch
einfach mal kommentare zu schreiben
beziehungsweise kommentare nur hoch zu
werten wenn die wirklich für mich von
vorteil sind beziehungsweise wenn ihr
sagt okay das ist wirklich etwas was man
als kommentar bezeichnen kann weil sowas
wie like und du bist toll oder so das
bin ich nur noch abfällt ich hoffe ihr
verstanden was ich damit sagen wollte
mich fax einfach bei mir ein wenig ein
video hochgeladen haben
mit anzuschauen oder so eine scheiße zu
lesen das macht mich einfach traurig
übrigens habe ich die ganze zeit gerade
hier vor der kamera gekniet und meine
knie tun hat wäre ich hoffe ihr versteht
so ein bisschen was ich sagen wollte
mich fangen die kommentare einfach ab
deswegen deaktiviere ich die bewertung
zu sieben tage ist der ultra cool wenn
ihr dieses video euren freunden schickt
weil ich das irgendwie da ganz viele
leute ankommen werden und sagen werden
über hatte die bewertung ausgemacht hat
der an zwei displays oder so und dann
bedanke ich mich fürs zuschauen
bis bald